your eyes okay this is your world from
your POV top five greatest of all time
Fighters don't forget about it you can
put Pride you can put Bellator you can
put UFC you can put anything who do you
put as top five um which Gracie needs to
be in it you know uh I don't look at the
last fights what he did for MMA uh
sakuraba beating four Graces he should
be in it Federal milianenenko he should
be in it Ronda Rousey should be in
really Ronda Rousey because she changed
the world's Game Changer she was the one
that you know so all these things where
they talk about the Mount Rushmore it's
a very hard one yeah I mean Habib
they're such a freak athletes right now
and they're all good everywhere like
with me I was just good on the ground
and standing and I had a boatload of
stamina but now everybody has that and
they're way better wrestlers than I was
so the the level is much higher you're
not putting yourself in the top five no
no listen and always say and they say
top hundreds I always say this and I
mean this from the bottom of my heart if
I'm in the top thousand I'm a very happy
man